I know that first of all you are
Canadian yeah and I love Canadians and I
love all of Canada they've always been
very good to me
I'm guessing you travel a lot then you
commute almost between where Canada and
we're in Canada in Toronto so you go
from Toronto to LA back every three
weeks yeah Toronto here no that's good
Mounties in the back let's not get
exhausting you like to fly yeah I've
never liked flying but I you know I'm
sort of I'm getting over in a little bit
but I my whole thing is like I like to
clock how everyone's doing when I get on
the plane you know what I mean like I
got I like to get eyes on the captain I
like to see how he's doing does he look
hungover did he look ill is he alright
my clock the stewardess I said check
them out see if they're you look at
other passengers like oh yeah recently
actually which is always a good way to
distract yourself from the fear of
flying is when you can catch eyes with
someone who is a little awkward like I
was sitting next to a woman who actually
was eating pudding without a spoon and
refused to have a spoon and was slurping
it out of the cup this was like this
thing and I was like this but what why
was she spoon did they offer her a spoon
well no this is my way no me I would
like I would like this I was like can we
can we get this a spoon I don't know I
don't want to speak didn't think I was
like okay she doesn't want a spoon and
then the guy across from her was like
this just doing that to her he did not
want to see it I wasn't getting grossed
out by it but I was like I find it
erotic myself
they're watching fantastic that's not
what I was imagining it was amazing you
eat pudding for me more often you sorry
I like anyone tuning in at that moment
you are dating a hockey player back in
Toronto that is a very violent dangerous
sport just worried you are you worried
about your boyfriend no I mean I I he
knows what he's doing but I do get
sometimes it gets it gets scary I mean
this year we had a little bit of a thing
where I was actually at the game and he
got hit in the face with him with it
with a puck got it in the face yeah I
blocked a shot and I was I was really
really upset and run back down and
waited for the doctors to hear if he's
okay and which is a very you know tense
moment and and the doc comes out and
said okay Lee show you know we're gonna
come back and go see him and just you
know
brace yourself make sure you're you know
he's bracers well he said he doesn't
look good I mean doesn't look good but
he's fine he's fine I was like thank God
he's fine but like you know stay strong
don't freak him out on his face don't
wake him out he has no we have his face
here you can take it home
Cihan so he's so they said you know just
be just don't freak him out and I got
this I you know come around the corner
react to that it was like I screamed cuz
his he had a big fat guys and bloc I was
about my god I really looks great little
sick about it
he had a pup coming out of his head it
looks good that's fine fine else
watering rule it out that's what that is
I don't know that was a tough call
[Applause]
the two of us are like mating calls this
is weird i re ice this show